[音楽]
ran
[拍手]
ああああああ
皆さんところで反逆してますか
これ入って答えると言いませんよね普通ねアドできることならまあね反逆とか品が楽な
んだけど
まあ我々の人生にはやっぱ泡がはなきゃならない時ってのがあるじゃないですか
例えばダイエットとかでもそうですよダイエットってすごいよね相方
食欲に争うさらに高垂れ下がっていくに行く引っ張る地球の重力やらが生まれも抗い
の集大成ですよであのそう言うねあの争いっていう中ではねだいたい争いつのは支配的
な価値観に争うっていうケースが多いですね
でこの争い方ってのはだいたい3パターンです
一つは革命がー
支配的な価値観を転覆し破壊して新しい価値観をこのように家建てる人で2つ目
反逆者
これは支配的な価値観を添付しないんだけど
新しい価値観を認めさせる1
3つ目
駄々をこねる1
ね支配的価値がに不平不満はゆんですけれども
時々餌を与えればおとなしくなる人たちです
ハイ3種類学メーカー反逆者
駄々をこねる1これで残念なことなんですけど
3番目もいいんですよ
ダブル人が一番でときどき s男もらえればもうちょっとおとなしくなっちゃう人が
多いんですよね
でこれそのままでいいのかって言うとそのままだとずーっとそれの繰り返しなんですよ
あの支配的価値だの言いなりでまぁその人自身の立場も良くならない村長もされない
ですじゃあ革命でもやるかーってやらないですよね
すげー大変だもんねで大手頃なのが反逆なんですよ
なんとで反逆っつーのはあのまあ誰でもできるんです
コツさえ分かってればでそのコツ増強僕が伝授したいと思いますで今紹介にあったよう
に僕はの基本的なまず東京で
コンドルズっていうダンスチームをプロデュースしてますで地元の
静岡では静岡市民文化会館とタッグを組んで
ラウド昼計画というのをやってます総監督ですでこのラウン昼計画ってなんだなって
いうと地方から文化を発信し妖精っていう会なんですねまぁつまるところ
東京の中央分解の反逆です
でこれ元々はね僕の音だだこねから始まったんですよ
でどんなだこれかというとこのままでは静岡がなんかつまんないじゃんって駄々をこね
てたんです
でこれを反逆の底に仕立て上げてまあ進めてるわけです
なので事例としてはその辺を引っ張りつつあの反逆のコツを4つ
4つにまとめて話したいと思います
でまずだだこねと反逆の違いなんだがありますか
価値観があるかないかです
ただこう不満をね喚いてるだけの大だこネッツんはまた喚いてるだけなんですけど反逆
つのまあ
駄々こねてる背景に何か新しい味だもあるんじゃねーのって相手に思わせることなん
ですよ
本当は何もなくていいです
相手が思えばいいんですからここポイントですで支配的な価値観っていうの武器は差
あれなんですよね数の力
じゃあ新しい価値観って何が武器
オリジナリティです
さあオリジナリティーけど無理無理そんな私無理っていうといっぱいあると思うんです
よ
でもれこれが簡単なんですよ何をすればいいか
真逆をするんです
反逆のことその1真逆をする
これその中央分解の反逆という意味で考えていますをどうするのか
ちょっとイメージしましょうあの全国展開してるアイドルグループがいるとしますね
はい
容易に想像がつきますね皆さんねあの全国からオーディオして全国に通用する曲改定
なんかちょっとアティねっ全国アジアに打っていきますよなんて言う人がどぅでこう
いう人たちた
して反逆は間逆をやればいいんです
出演者は静岡県民限定でお話は静岡が舞台
ストーリーも静岡オリジナル静岡でた満載で観客も静岡県民以外想定しない
もうね隣の県の山梨とが他の県の人がいても全然面白くないのねそういうものを作って
静岡県民だけが感動するものを作るんですよ
ちょっと変でしょこれ
上すでにおかしいでしょこれ要するにちゃんとが逆をやれば誰だと駄々こねにちょっと
ユーモアが宿るんですよっていうのが宿るとコンセプトがあるように見えてくるんです
ねでおのずとオリジナリティあるんじゃねぇって形になるんですよ
恐るべきことにこれが反逆のポイントコツその1
真逆をすること入っ
でそうなってくるとねだんだん人が集まってるんです
これ面白そうだね集まってくるでここでしなきゃいけないことがあるんですよ
それ何か
閉じること
閉じるんです a これねほらこうある程度人が集まっていた段階で当時なきゃダメな
んですよ
で見極めところはちょっと派閥ができかけた時
アッここで土地だっ閉じることが大事なんですで当時ラって言うとみんなイメージは
あるんでしょ
でもね騙されちゃだめだのあの反逆やってる初期段階っていうのはオリジナリティが
すげー弱い理由
でここで閉じないとどんどんいろんな音情報が入ってきて平均化されちゃうんだろ
でさらに高やっぱ支配的な価値が似合っていう間にね瞬殺されちゃうので
でまぁネットなんかちょっと危ないですよあれネットボス不平不満かけるたんですが
本当にスカッとするんだけどあれ反逆の女が摘み取られてるんですよ
もうねただの音反逆の音がダダ声に彼は
入ってるんですだから皆さん思う存分としください
反逆の初期段階では思う存分閉じて良いですで
なのでここで反逆のコツは2個目が思い切り閉じることじゃビートルズでバンドあり
ますよね
ピートローズデバンドってねロンドン出身じゃないんですよリバプールです
地方都市の音港町ですよ祖母のライブのたたき上げのバンドですからね
新しいねー
独自性のある価値観っていうのは常に
異質の集団から閉鎖的なばから生まれてくるんです
これは間違いないんです
さあ次はねぇ
メンタルの問題に行きましょう
反逆する人たちのメンタルこれがねぇすっげー不安定なんですよ
あの
こんなことやってて何の意味なんだろうとさ
この先どっせるんだろうとかねこんな何年も時間割く必要兄ちゃんだと思っちゃった
ジェフおばあちゃんですよ
でそんな時に餌がポーンて投げ込まれるとまあいっかってになりがちなんですよね
でこれを回避するにはどうしたらいいでしょうか
メジャー感をつけることです
お前さっきと白釣ったジャンドゥね真逆だろてめーたらしいですけど
9ポイントはメジャーになることじゃないんですよメジャー感をつけることです
このただのね駄々こねから始まったことがねこれもしだして
しゃっ母の役に立つんじゃねなんか
立派なことなんじゃね簡単にあきらめちゃいけねぇんじゃねぇこれっていうね自信を
抱かせることが大事なんですよで僕のやっではアヌー計画で作った1作目という
はですねあのジェリー jリーグ史上初の jリーグに実在する
普通の球団を舞台にした清水エスパルス公認オフィシャルミュージカルってやつなん
ですよで3作目は静岡県がね全県あの徳川家康さんお祝いしてるとしてきたのでそこに
絡めて
得
が家康顕彰400年記念事業
牛銘打ったんですよもうこの時点でメジャー感半端な所
静岡の人なら何がメジャーのことやってねこいつら立派じゃねえと
でもこれ蓋を開けてみればただ僕がエスパルスと静岡県に頭下げてちょっと方が気化し
てもらえませんかとお願いしただけなんだけどこれだけでも立派にメジャー感が作っ
であの去年からなんですけどねあの子のローヒール計画に参加してる景気銚子高生 jk
たちを静岡
ライダーのメディアである静岡放送の sb スラー所に投入したんですよ
で今3人でレギュラー番組をやってるんですねこうなってくるとそのプロジェクトに
参加してる人たちはああれっ
こういう人が俺達のから出るんだぜじゃあアンドゥでこれええまぁちょっと難しいかも
だけど
もっと簡単な方法があるんですよ皆さん入り口でもらったかもしれませんがチラシあり
ますかね
あの
いただきましょうか
このチラシにもらった入ってますか
これですこれもう見るからに高そうなチラシでしょ
表ピカピカこれ pp 加工つんですけどすんげーだけですよ
あの東京でもトップランクのこれチラシなんですねでこういうチラシを作ることなん
です
これ作るとどうなるか3場所の皆さんが胸を張って配るんですよチラシを
あの処分打ち出さとさ前乗り t 我慢さで配るつないしょみんなもねでもこういう
しっかりしたものを作るだけで堂々と配れるんです
でもらったもなんかこれすげーことやってんじゃねーのとではたしたもまあすごいこと
やってるよねって言えるわけですよね
これ大事なんですだからこうやってあの手この手を使ってね
メジャー感
をつけて食ったものすごい大事でそれによって本当はただの駄々こねだったものがいつ
まにか胸を張れるものに変わっちゃうんですよ
恐ろしいことに国家覚えてくださいあの何か商品を作る時でもチラシをしっかり作れば
それだけで営業する人の気持ちて上がるんですよね
メジャー感は大事なんです
そしてですねいよいよあの4つ目なんですけども
反逆のことを4つにはですね時間を味方につけることです
般若たというのはですね何して時間がかかる
時間ながらもですまぁだいたいそのね年齢的にも保守的になってるね
あの上層部の皆さんをねそういう人の価値観を崩して認めさせることですからこれ時間
かかりますよ
でもここを逆手に取らないとダメです
時間がかかることも最初からわかってるわけですよ皆さんねもうわかってるんですから
あの例えば初期の段階であんまり物事がね
うまくいかなかったときはこう言えばいいんですよ俺たちで実は位の突破口を開こうと
この一言ですさらに短期的なところで赤字になったりしますよね
でもこんなにも決まってますよこれは未来への投資だ
この台詞にします
量はハッタリをかませるところですドカーンと音でも力強く断言しなきゃダメなんです
よ
でちなみによく僕が使うねあの言葉これなんですよね
あかちの赤は情熱まあか
これだいたい行けますよねえこういったことをやってくると
あの本当にでただの大だこでだったにも関わらず参加者たちはもう屋根
歴史的使命感を感じるんですよ恐ろしいことでこれは俺たちがやらなければいけないと
長悠久の歴史の中で俺たちが傘の開けたのだとそういう気持ちになってテンションが
上がってるんですよねそうですだから時間がかかると分かっているものは最初からも
時間を味方
につけなきゃダメなんですよ
これで以上4点なんですがまず整理しますと
まず1つ目反逆のコツの一つ目は真逆をすること
二つ目はドジること
3つ目はメジャー感をつけること
4つ目は時間を味方につけることをこれ以上4点なんですが
さらに重要なことがあるんですよ
それはですね叛逆っていうのは
自分がね
自分らしく生きる場を獲得するための手段なんです
誰かへの復讐じゃないんですよ
だから大事なことはやり過ぎてはいけないってことです
あくまでも君自身の価値観を認めさせればいいんですから
それは同時に相手の価値観を認めることです
で更にもう一つ大事なことはやはり続けることです
いつかね未来の世代がね反逆なんかしなくてもいい
叛逆なんかしなくても幸せに暮らしていけるそういうの中それをつくっていくことに
繋がってるんだということを自覚してください
そして
最後になりますが
皆さんにねもう一つだけお伝えしたいことがあるんです
ここまでねあの僕が話して来て話これはね
キレイさっぱり忘れてくれていいです
あの誰しもが別に各メーカーになる人のてないんですよ
ですね反逆者にならなくてもいい
ねっ
人生ただだをこねて生きたっていいんです
人の生き様はそれぞれですでも一つだけ
一つだけお願いしたい
それはですね
もしも
与えられた餌が腐っていたら
その腐ったへさせていってください
それは最低限
人間としての誇りです
[拍手]